und die fragen was sind das für kids das
ist doch ein netzwerk sie lesen wie
bibel und machen daraus ein mixtape
unter hatte schon so ein kleiner projekt
komm mal runter abidi masala baby balla
herzlich kommt so einige leute ich habe
heute max an meiner seite und wir werden
heute zusammen auf christliche rapper
reagieren leute werden im heutigen video
auf christliche rapper reagieren und das
sind zwei sachen die in unseren augen
nicht so krass gut zusammen passen
deshalb schauen wir heute gemeinsam mit
euch an was aber ganz klar sein sollte
jeder soll die religion auszuüben wie er
will wir sind beide christlich getauft
und würden dementsprechend niemals
irgendjemand was vorschreiben wollen
deshalb das training aber man darf auch
über alle sachen genau leute ich würde
gar keinen rechtlichen vortrag halten
aber wir haben in deutschland
meinungsfreiheit und religionsfreiheit
deswegen kann machen was er will und ich
kann dir da auch was dazu sagen was der
andere macht und dann kann man sich
nicht wirklich beleidigt wenn jetzt aber
so super gläubig seid dann ist das video
wahrscheinlich nicht für euch lustig ihr
solltet euch vielleicht einfach nicht
anschauen
genau wir starten rein denn unser
untersuchungsobjekt am heutigen tage ist
niemand geringeres als die groß
wir gucken uns heute die autos an und
die autos sind zwei brüder wie wir beide
die rappen aber nicht irgendwie sondern
über jesus die bibel mosel einfach über
alles was du fresh & co das alles was
hip hop ist ja das hat die sache ist das
sind so zwei themen die man eigentlich
nicht zusammenbringen würde weil die war
so kirche für uns gott für uns immer so
vorne auf der kanzel steht und fahrrad
sagte du musst das und du darfst das auf
gar keinen fall sonst gibt's ärger und
wies web so eine mutter ich verkaufe
drogen so robra
chicago wartet es mich kurz mal machen
[Musik]
ja die opossum auf eigenen kanal leute
und deren mainz gekipptes haben diesen
kanal bis der song bodies die wir das
mal anschauen und ja also ich habe viel
versehen wenn ihr immer noch dran seid
und das trotzdem checkt auf ihr vor den
kanal ab so wenn es allerding ist dann
abonniert doch nie gerne wenn jetzt
sollte dabei sind die feiern sofort
abonnierte und research
ok also dass das setting soll dieses
video beginnt aus so einer partie eine
ganz normale partie scheinbar irgendwie
so wahrscheinlich von irgendwelchen
freunden und natürlich sind die autos
auch an wir sind aber nicht lange wissen
sonntags führers klar was machen wir
jetzt morgen gottesdienst dass hier bis
5 zu verschlafen
nein gottesdienst wenn man sein leben im
griff hat anders als die ganzen kanal
und es ist 16 46 18 uhr ist für mich
nicht in versuchung erreichte seinen
neuesten film die brücke die beiden
fäusten gerade auf den weg natürlich um
frisch nachzugehen wollten gerade können
gehen um morgens fit zu sein im
gottesdienst und da kommen auf einmal
diese
diese kümmern ich gehe nach hause ja
gottes ziehen unsere computer seine
herkunft nicht kurzem ein ab und ich
sage das jetzt nach antalya kommen auf
jeden fall diese zwei - und wollen die
jungs davon abhalten am ort
hast du das gesehen hat sich also klar
bei yoga die will den christen
es ist ja gar zu groß meinte wort fällt
zurück und muss sich permanent also okay
das ist schaller panda ist das eine
beleidigung die erfunden haben damit die
keine unchristlichen wörter sagen müssen
vielleicht der bande
was ist havanna ist der bruder von salus
controls die lappen
wir gehen jetzt erst mal ein paar immer
das haben wir direkt einen von diesen
nicht christlich rettende news
der coole muss sein daher kenne ich mich
auch ein stück weit selbst drin weil ich
gehalten ist und die kirche
und wenn jetzt nicht so oft zu wenig
anbeten opfer einfach das also dass bin
glaube ich ja also outfit muss auch vor
gut gewählt die die church es selbst so
so kann man nicht sagen also kann man da
nicht helfen so die jungs sehen
wahrscheinlich schon gut aus man sagen
und dann so ein so aus den 80ern flohen
mit so einer phobie leader ist deshalb
klar ich meine sowie soll der mensch
aussehen wenn er nicht christlichen
report
wir machen nicht es reicht jetzt wenn
braucht und was man sich alles sind hier
verteilte ja ja gerade angekommen was
passiert was für die zehn davon sehen
die wollte gerade mit mir weiter
gott sei dank dort stellen jugend gutes
weglaufen ist das wollen wir das nicht
schön bruder what the [ __ ] da fängt
schon direkt an so sagt das hätte sicher
dass ihr das so christentum ein hobby
ist egal was ich das für eine athletin
gegen die er gibt dir das mal jeder in
dieser gang ist mir diese theorie
weniger
jeder ist aber so krank gibt ja ich
hab's mir anders überlegt was auch geil
geil auf der skala gibt es dafür 5 von 5
punkten also die sache ist ja wir haben
das video schon vorfreude von uns
geschaut so die haben wir alle vermisste
gewünschte man von aber dann vokabular
ist natürlich auch beschränkt wird du
kannst dich über arbeit oder über das
was sich wasser kapha lederkoffer leila
wetter ist ein eiscafé ist leila wetters
nachbar ist heiß kann nur so viel sagen
aber wir bieten nicht deswegen ist als
geistige masse phase wichtig
keiner weniger weg ok geistige masse
phase wird auch zum ersten mal sowas hab
den ersten öffentlich stärker bin live
op kannst du dich bitte kurz ich mehr
rhythmus konzern stellt keiner weniger
sektor stellen mit den chips
wir leben gesund also ich weiß dass da
dürfte man so gar nichts machen was man
lernt hier sein können ohne mir zu
justieren
das ist sozial und deutschrap und
trinken ein smoothie wir leben gesund
man muss so in jedem bereich im leben
einfach perfekt diszipliniert so du
darfst nicht chips essen
das komplett hängen geblieben im alter
bis geistige masse frage ja längst du
dich doch nur ab schläfst du sonntags
lang opfer war heute jetzt noch einmal
der ja das ist einfach perfekt
kontrolliert
guck mal da gehe ich nicht hier seht ihr
denn so einer der keine smoothies trinkt
sagt er seine beste phase dieser
checkliste heute zu gott gebetet dass
geistige masse phasen trainiert sie
getrunken
läuft komplett bodybuilder sein leben
auseinander genommen also die sache ist
wirklich glauben die menschen zu
analysieren würde werden glaube ich
diese jungs so leute diese ultra
diszipliniert sind die schwaben auf save
mit 1,0 abitur gemacht und studiert
medizin oder irgendwie gleicht so weil
die lassen einfach keinen keine
versuchung irgendwie an sich ran so
glaube ich aber weil es sich ja alles
was die leute sagen der weg bringen
die ladegut geistige schokolade
man muss man alles und geistig zu sehen
da kannst du physisch schokolade haben
so etwas wollen würden wir zur geistigen
labello füße trocken
egal was man geistig nach einer shisha
rauchen und sie fragt was sind das für
kids
das ist doch ein netzwerk sie lesen die
bibel und machen daraus ein mixtape ja
ja aber er wie gesagt die check-ins
selbst es ist einfach nur fakten komisch
als ich meine jungs wenn ihr das fühlt
kann aber klar ich meine dass
deutschland so frei wenn ich will kann
ich morgen über zugestanden rappen oder
über die farbe meiner socken so die
sache ist auch die orders sind ja nicht
klein sind ja nicht unbekannt wir haben
richtig krasse community weil ich finde
es ist gar nicht so präsent in unserem
alltag ist es gibt super krass
christliche community also von jungen
leute die ihm sympathisch machen so
soboll schippen und und das ist einfach
nur nicht so krassen der öffentlichkeit
und die sind macht die sind nicht
unbekannt oder so sondern die haben das
werde jetzt auch noch anschauen
eine chance spiele ich da vor 10 oder 20
tausend lauras krank geisteskranker also
ich glaube in der community so sind die
risiko ist richtig das ist die
körperliche liebe rentenalter richtig
hilft da braucht man wirklich klappt
selbst
die bibel machen daraus ein mixtape
darunter habe
das ist schon ein kleiner sagt markus
ist sondern die germanen com herunter
abidi rottweil jobs sind auch deutsche
als alles was ich jemals gesehen habe so
ihre ganze kurve sind so richtige so bio
deutsche komm mal runter habibi
ballaballa es ist nicht so morgens ohne
morgens einfach eine stunde oder ja wenn
man so unbeherrscht damit unregelmäßig
trainieren geht wenn man geistig gemacht
hat
aber wenn sie dann ist alleine 24
stunden naja das ist einfach
leistungssport rapper mittwoch bühne
da ist so kein arzt gesagt hast du dass
du deine mutter zurück so sind die
kinder von dem papier da oben ich habe
heute schon eins wurde getrunken und sie
kaufen meine spacken und schon wir sind
die kinder von den papieren sind am
schönen mit den hat er gerade das
lyrische du besitzt was bitte stört sie
das droht da fragt man sagt ich dich
nicht gerne bild wir wollen doch dieser
schritt ist verrückt aber waters er
sieht das lyrische ich war aber keiner
links sieht einfach so diebe wieso der
grunge frau aus sänger der sieht aus wie
keine ahnung sieht so stelle ich mich
schon wenn das für euch bin nicht so ein
bildet wieder aussieht ja das ist
übelste schöniger und wer bist du über
männer jung und erst jetzt mal spaß weil
ganz unter uns ihr könntet so krank
jetzt mal ohne vista hallo also soweit
das musikvideo gebe ich noch weiter aber
dass wir zusammen in diesem video wir
schauen noch mal in den live auftritt
beim race camp 2018 empire und stets
kleiner zusammenschnitt vom auftritt
beim race camp in basel mit 6000 leuten
geisteskrank international auftritt vor
5000 leuten geisteskranken nicht fertig
wir haben den lebendig
sie können uns nicht sie mein lieber
zuhörer können uns niemals bändigen so
die mich zu bändigen braten
das ist so frustrierend machen leute
das ist so absurd zurück macht ja alle
was wir wollen aber es ist so wird wenn
man die jugendsprache und hip hop mit
gott und der kirche mit gottes segen an
weg mein hass und danke
[Musik]
junge ottensheim rangeht mit also die
haben energy auf jeden fall muss das
muss noch vereine ziehen ihr ding durch
sodass ich kann man auf jeden fall haben
also wie gesagt heute noch hält an die
beiden jungstars ist ganz cool ist
aufgebaut und auch wenn es halt nicht so
unsere welt ist jetzt dass wir müssen
bewusst machen kann man es schon
supporten wenn ich noch kurz etwas sagen
dürfte gottes segen euch video
ihr könnt ihr abonnieren